49 of 50 states have now partially eased
social distancing rules but the pandemic
is far from over the reported u.s death
toll
from the coronavirus has surpassed 90
thousand people
now more businesses are looking for ways
to safely reopen
while the danger remains david begneau
is in front of an apple store here in
new york david good morning
you know how busy a apple store can be
tony everybody inside touching all those
devices
pressing something that somebody else
just touched so what are big brands like
apple going to do to change the rules
number one
you've got to wear a mask before you go
in when the store reopens mask applies
to customers and employees that's the
rule also they're going to take your
temperature before you're allowed inside
and they're going to restrict how many
people can go in because they want to
maintain a social distance
that's what the big brand guys like
apple can do it's going to be
interesting to see what the mom and pop
shops around the country
end up doing and are able to do as more
people continue to reopen around the
country
cautiously 48 auto manufacturing plants
across eight states are back open now
that means tens of thousands of
employees at ford gm and fiat chrysler
are back at work
my wife's a nurse my sons are cops i'm
ready
let's go let's get this done we got to
do it sooner or later video from this
chrysler plant in warren michigan shows
their new normal
temperature checks upon entry to the
building two masks are given to each
employee
plastic coverings to keep employees
separated workers consistently
sanitizing their work stations
even with all of that some people were a
little uneasy about going back to work
i know personally five people that
passed away from this
four of them were tier one worked next
door
so we're scared the auto industry is
part of america's economic engine trying
to get back on track
as governors around the country continue
to slowly reopen
in texas yesterday governor greg abbott
reopened gyms office buildings and child
care centers with some restrictions
there are plans to reopen bars in
bowling alleys on friday
washington state announced the reopening
of all medical services
and massachusetts will be the second to
last state in the country
to ease restrictions that states
governor charlie baker announced his
state's
strict four-phase plan these two
will be inseparable getting back to work
and fighting covid until there's a
medical breakthrough with treatments
or a vaccine 21 states are still seeing
an increase in new positive cases
that's why some governors are a little
hesitant to open
too much too soon
among those unhappy with their state's
slower pace the owners of this gym in
new jersey
who believe the governor's stay-at-home
order violates their constitutional
rights
if big box retailers grocery and liquor
stores can operate
with proper health protocol in place so
can every single business
in america back here on the upper west
side of manhattan yesterday police here
in new york city
shut down a yeshiva which is an orthodox
jewish school
video shows about 60 kids pouring out of
the building
reportedly very few of them were wearing
masks the city got a tip that the school
was operating and so they went in to
shut it down
the mayor of new york city bill de
blasio actually tweeted about this
saying that they were going to
issue a cease and desist order he put
out the tweet because he clearly wanted
people to know what they were doing
and gail he was trying to send an
example the city will not tolerate
the defiance of city orders
all right david begna on the move on
upper west side i recognize that corner
thank you david